good morning millennials
today's episode is brought to you by IHG
hotels and resorts IHG hotels and
resorts is the hotel company made up of
over 6 000 hotels and 17 amazing Brands
Brands like Kimpton Hotels and
restaurants InterContinental Hotels and
Resorts Holiday Inn Express six senses
and more they are taking care of their
guests this holiday season with
exclusive benefits such as member
discounts a bonus points offer when
downloading the new ihg-1 rewards mobile
app catalog savings on travel gear and
more ie's all new loyalty program IHG
One Rewards makes it that much easier to
check out and redeem these can't miss
offers right in the palm of your hand
with the new ihg-1 rewards mobile app
you must be a member to get these
amazing rewards so don't wait to sign up
ihe is passionate in its belief that
when people are taken care of they feel
free to be themselves and live their
best lives that is straight facts no
lies were spoken there's nothing better
than feeling like yourself being
comfortable and having all of the
amenities you could ever want ihe's
latest campaign is called guess how you
guessed and it's all about traveling in
a way that is personal and meaningful to
you so honestly traveling is more
personal than comedy more personal than
food and everybody likes a little
different something special when they
arrive I know for mclartia when she
arrives she's like a real housewife she
wants a cocktail upon arrival she wants
it with a fruit and she wants it with an
umbrella for me I need the best
accommodations for my baby boy Bryce we
need plush dog beds we need dog bowls
maybe a little treat for my boy if
you're making Bryce feel comfortable I
am feeling comfortable
so with IHG One Rewards you'll get
access to all of these amazing benefits
through the ihg-1 rewards mobile app for
more details on how to maximize your
travels this holiday season with IHG
hotels and resorts cyber offerings
guests can follow at IHG One Rewards on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter or you
can visit ihg.com cyber sale traveling
is such a wonderful Excursion but you've
got to do it in the way that you are
most comfortable with and rewards
benefits and being a member at ihg-1
rewards is what's going to help you get
there so check it out welcome back to
the toast and happy uh Tuesday
who's day I hope everyone's having a
great Tuesday thus far hey Jax how you
doing I'm doing good I have one thing to
say howdy howdy howdy cloudy
um Jax and I are both wearing sweaters
today from show me your Momo like not
that um
they haven't but like they should
sponsor the show because like they
basically do no and we talk about how
much we love their stuff and they
actually did reach out to send us some
stuff but we'll still keep placing
orders and no like what else am I
supposed to wear yeah and it's like I
don't have the time to like wait for the
email exchange like I just want I want
my order my clothes now literally
literally I actually just got a huge
haul from them I got this howdy sweater
also they have a matching sweater for
babies that says howdy and it's white
with sad beige writing so it's girl or
boy so I got one for Harry too so when
you come you have to bring your sweater
we can all be matching oh my God I'm
gonna die that's so cute I got some
bathing suits and trying them on was
enlightening upsetting it was
enlightening to see oneself
in the new bathing suit I just feel like
um bathing suits are really
um like unnecessary
but not for you because you really swim
for me they're really not necessary I
don't swim I may be swim like twice on a
vacation like the nights I'm gonna wash
my hair and that's it
that's true I am a swimmer but that's
not what I meant I meant like the
concept that we have to swim and
sunbathe in the nude is kind of like
[ __ ] like why can't we all just be
wearing like leotards like down to our
ankles well I do feel like rash guard
bathing suits are kind of really in
right now like long sleeve bathing suits
and also ones that have like a little
short short maybe that's in the future
for you
I just find the bathing suit industry to
be like extremely triggering
um and just a really an unnecessary uh
corporate moment I feel like the bathing
suit industry
is really missing something and that's
yes recognition that people have of the
big breasted women and that you can have
big titties that aren't fake and so what
you need is support it's not that
everyone either has fake titties or is
flat chested like where are the bathing
suit tops and even one pieces because
one pieces have no support you might as
well just put an invisible string on and
walk into the sea but where are the
bathing suits
I want a bathing suit top that's my bra
in scuba material that's it that's all I
want about asking for anything
no I completely agree and like I don't
know what what world people are living
in that like bathing suits still come
with pads like we don't need pads
and I just feel like there's so many
different bathing suit companies that
are targeted for like different body
types there's literally none for big
breasted women except like shout out to
Miracle swim which is like literally
bathing suits and not everyone wants to
wear a miracle swimsuit no because like
Loki most of them are ugly and they're
literally 200 for a one piece but like
they're built really well they're made
of like literal like elastic like
they're so tight on your boobs thank God
yes but it's also like sometimes I want
to wear a bikini I don't want to wear
like a miracle suit that's working the
whole body like I really mostly need the
rest of my body can fend for itself my
boobs can't and like they need support
and I need Brands even if Miracle suit
like wants to put their material into
just a top and
the rest can be like cute bathing suit
material like the thing about Miracle
suit it might as well say Miracle suit
on it I know it's like a miracle suit
and it's really for people in nursing
homes like that is the target demo and I
just feel like there are girlies out
here who aren't in nursing homes who
need that Vibe as well and it's hard
because with me it's like I want support
for my breath so I need it to be tight
where so that it's like
sucking too but like I also need it to
get over my boobs it's it's a very fine
line I feel like I have one bathing suit
from every brand
that works for me but I need a line of
bathing suits that are tit conscious
I think the brand to do it is Spanx like
they really need to get into the swim
category yeah
but it I it's giving Miracles too no
because Spanx clothing is like very
trendy and cute I feel like they could
do it like I really do I'm gonna give
this job to Sarah Blakely and I feel
like she won't let me down yeah they
could definitely throw their hat in the
ring but I also want like Trend not
styled by the way this isn't to say like
not everyone needs to make bathing suits
for big tits women like I just need one
or two to focus on it to say hey we've
got your back literally you literally to
have big fake titties in order to wear
our swimsuits and you don't need to be
flat chested or have a b or even C Cups
like let's yeah let's start a line
called C plus
C plus and I know everyone's going to
comment like try this brand I've tried
it like it doesn't work like
there's a difference between having
boobs and having big boobs like there's
a difference and if you know you know
and if you don't like if you put your
blessings and stop wishing that you had
big boobs yeah because if you can throw
your boob over your shoulder like we're
not the same you know Continental
Soldier right
do your boobs hang low do they wobble to
the flow can you tie them in a knot can
you tie them in a bow can you throw them
over your shoulder like a continental
Soldier do your boobs hang low hey they
do I'm actually wearing a bra today it's
like one of those Comfort bras but it
has
padding and structure from a new sponsor
of ours me too
have we done a read for Bare Necessities
yet have not I think oh there are new
sponsor of ours and I've been living at
this bra I haven't watched it since I
got it it's a great sweater bra because
I realized I don't want to wear my
everyday bra when I wear a sweater
because it like makes my boobs look big
which they are I want a bra that's gonna
like flatten them
so no that's right
it sounds like what you and I actually
need are breast reductions yeah we do
but we also need Solutions and we need
solution materials and not everything
can be so drastic like not everyone is
in a position to have surgery
I know and I have been
um really really like I've always said a
breast reduction is something I'm going
to do in the future but like the day I
think is coming I have been experiencing
I've had big boobs my whole life and
everyone always complains about back
pain and like let me say I would
complain with them but like I never
low-key had back pain up until six
months ago I cannot do my makeup I
cannot do a show without literally like
limping off stage my back is not okay I
have like so many reservations about
getting a breast reduction like I know
all the benefits I'm just like nervous
I've never had surgery before like the
anesthesia like I do want to breastfeed
I mean who knows but like that's
something I would like to do when I have
children and I know that like that can
change like there's a lot of things like
that are going against my decision but
like the back
I can't believe the back came for you my
back didn't start hurting with my boobs
until I was breastfeeding well that
makes sense they tripled in size no and
also just labor is hard on your back and
it's it's a very back
oriented experience
so backwards so twisted
um
I got my show me your moo moo delivery I
ordered some bathing suits half were
petrifying really quite spooky and the
other half were were good but they were
again like high-waisted bikinis that
also all the bikinis that I wear in
order to have support they need to be
like that athletic cut and it's like
like sports I don't have any yeah like a
sports bra exactly which I love and
that's my go-to but sometimes I don't
want to have like an athletic Vibe I
want to be like beachy or something so I
think maybe instead of like a bathing
suit I need a butler to just walk around
and hold my boobs on his forearm or her
do you remember that brand from Shark
Tank that towel that's for your boobs
Tata towels I have one so here like I
don't use mine really uh that often I
like it though and I love the idea and I
love the technology and they need to put
something about that magic where like
your back is carrying your boobs up
in a bathing suit
no you're by the way Tata towels is an
amazing brand I wish them the all the
best I completely agree that they might
be the company yeah they should foray
into swimsuits because the idea that
like you need your underboob to dry like
while you're getting ready like it'll
dry and it's not that urgent no it's
it's a decent problem not enough for me
to grab my Tata towel any more than
maybe once a year I think I liked it
when I was pregnant though
um what is like your favorite product
from Shark Tank
oh I mean you obviously have your answer
ready so you go first I don't actually
uh I do usually ask questions though
because I have an answer I need to think
of what I actually own from the tank
because I actually don't even have a
Scrub Daddy people are obsessed there's
literally like a cult on Tick Tock they
literally change it out once a week they
get new ones they do unboxings they're
obsessed
I can't my mind is drawing a blank
okay if here's a different question if
you went on Shark Tank with a company
who would you want to partner with hmm
I would have to look at all their
records
maybe Mr wondering
I think you know you and him would get
along we did we would because we are
honest to a fault you're honest girls
yeah I just also think that it really
depends on what type of product you have
it's like a household item obviously
you're gonna go with Lori if it's
something like Athletics Sports you want
to go with they all have their different
Niche if it's wine you definitely want
to go with Mr Wonderful
um and if you're dumb you want to go
with Robert so you're so wrong oh I was
with Robert in an elevator when I was in
New York City last time I forgot to tell
him what yeah
wait Robert and his wife did you do it
did you do an elevator pitch no I didn't
and I literally forgot about it until
this moment they were in the elevator
where at bergdorfs like of course
they're so fancy well I was there too so
that makes me fancy sorry oh you're
literally Heather Dubrow I was with Zach
and like of course I realized who it was
immediately but I I don't agree with
Harry what I was with Harry too so he's
everyone's like oh hi conversation
started um and then actually Zach said
something really normal which was that
oh I think we all have the same wedding
planner because we did
oh yeah you did and so they were like
yeah Mikey we love him we were like same
and then they got out on their floor I
think it was their floor or they were
running away from us right right right
these crazy wedding people yeah that's
actually like a good intro we I think we
handled it so normally
no that's so that's the second elevator
you've been in with a shark where you
didn't take the opportunity to elevate
or pitch I'm always in elevators with
sharks I was in the elevator with a
Damon on my bachelorette party
now I know this isn't Mr wonderful but I
was once in an elevator with Howie
Mandel
they look like irrelevant but wait
Jackie Jackie I too have been in an
elevator with Howie Mandel you were with
me right no I was in Montreal for just
for laughs oh I was at the Ritz
of course you were I was out like a
Marriott with me it was an event
it was literally so long ago it was the
first time I cut my hair short
where were we going it was um I think it
was an AGT America's Got Talent like
little party oh my God yes memory
unlocked we went to like an AGT launch
party yeah yeah yeah yeah
it sounds so much more fabulous I'm
gonna leave it there it was yeah you
weren't staying at the rib no not at all
I didn't even I just it was in the
location of the Ritz like okay here's
another question I have for you this is
just like my day of questions
um can I ask you a question no that's
not the question but there's this prompt
going around on Tick Tock it's like who
is like the most randomly famous person
that you have a photo with and
everyone's sharing like Serena Kerrigan
had a photo with Meghan Markle oh my god
when she was like a blogger yeah yeah
okay I need to
think because I rarely ask for a photo
you do but I also only ask the most
random people
um
why what's yours
I don't know I guess like the most
famous person I have oh is Leonardo
DiCaprio no random
no sorry the prompt is who's the most
famous person you have a photo like I
don't know why I said random probably
Miley Cyrus for me oh yeah when I was in
high school and I was obsessed Beyond
with her and I have to thank Olivia
because she made me get a picture
also The Veronicas oh that's like a core
memory for me yeah core memory and there
was someone else oh uh
madelaine petch I have a picture with
you also have a traumatizing story to go
along with it different picture
oh yeah oh yeah no just
tell me
no sorry don't meet like weird fans that
was me
no you were being nice
okay I'll stop I'll stop
um but no she's nice but we just like I
was you didn't connect
by the way I've told this story before I
think on the episode this is just random
unlocked memory the episode that we did
with the lady gang in the studio in the
sky I told them the story and I couldn't
even get it out I was laughing so hard
and like cringing so you guys if you
want the story go watch it because I'll
never tell it again
so that's a little bit about me
yeah what else is going on on tick tock
so much I mean we're blowing up like
it's just insane like our last couple of
Clips have really like performed we you
know we had a lull when we got 500 000
negative views about Miss Rach but we're
coming back bigger and better than ever
Claude
views our views no it's so true use
people our views people
no it's true so I see that as a win and
I'm really kind of coming into my tick
tocker era like I've just now gotten
another brand sponsorship just for my
Tick Tock like I'm really out here being
a tick tocker and if you follow me on
Tick Tock and you see my like sponsor
post like make sure to engage you know
like leave a comment okay so what was
the first one that you did
I've actually had like a couple
like so what's already live what's
coming out you can tell us about oh
Amazon is already Live Captain Crunch is
already Live Captain Crunch was a fairy
the ferry yeah uh I did another one I
can't remember but I've got a really big
one coming up oh exciting
yeah it was very exciting to be a tick
tocker like I I was so close to Fading
Into A relevancy like you know Meme girl
you never got she now I'm like number
one podcaster number one talker it's
good I'm happy for you I guess I'm also
that's the number one podcaster
of course wait wait so I'm happy for me
too and I'm Number One On Wheels
no and you're number one in our hearts
oh and that's really what matters
100 sure
and I'm number one on Goodreads which is
where I like to be
that's so true you invest in your Tick
Tock I'll invest in my Goodreads
and then we're covering all of our bases
here at the morning toast yeah speaking
of Goodreads I just finished the new
Kevin Wilson book he wrote nothing to
see here
and so his books are nice and short and
funny so I read his most recent one it's
called now is not the time to panic and
it was pretty Dreadful 2.5 stars for me
Claudia don't read it I'm sure Dana will
like it reminded me of tomorrow and
tomorrow tomorrow just because it was
like pessimistic and Dreadful about the
children not children young adults and
puberty people
um
so you know what it sounds like Jackie
that's my review what does it sound like
it sounds like
it sounds like you're being a hater and
I'm gonna put on my diff eyewear glasses
to block out the haters if that's okay
you know what that's okay
today is all about how your Chic eyewear
sunnies are pulling double duty for you
when you wake up and you're feeling not
Flawless these oversized trendy Shades
can handle life's little in-between
moments so we know that oversized
sunnies look super Glam and they can
make every outfit an actual fashion
moment but we love them because they
transcend fashion and they become a
functional need they look fabulous they
hide your eyes when you need it and
there are so many Chic oversized diff
Shades like the edgy Goldies or the Glam
Becky twos that really get the job done
they're basically hangover Shades
because after a little too much fun on a
Saturday night out heading out to brunch
the next day if you're feeling red puffy
eyes you've got a little bit of a light
sensitive headache bam throw in a pair
of oversized diff sunnies and you
instantly look put together hangover
gone so I am like really into oversized
sunglasses because I feel like there's a
myriad of of benefits but it makes my
face look smaller so I'm always out here
looking for like the biggest and baddest
if I wear I just got a huge package from
diff for my trip to Belize and I'm just
gonna be like people are gonna think I'm
a celebrity I mean you kind of like not
notice they'll be like that's that girl
from Tick Tock I just got my diff
eyewear package and now that I'm a
driver and I draw and I'm in Florida I
love two pairs of sunglasses in my car
for what sorry not my car like I'm
talking like I have my license a car the
car yesterday I went driving with Olivia
and obviously I forgot my sunglasses so
I took the ones from the car the diff
ones and they're so sickening we were
vlogging yesterday and I was like I'm
gonna get so many questions on how cute
these sunglasses are you like sunglasses
that really hide your face I like
sunglasses that like match my face and
blend in they have these like
tortoiseshell ones that were so cute and
then this morning I was driving again
yes because I'm just like taking to the
roads and I wore a different pair of
diffs and they were so damn cute
so if you have a bad breakup and you
spent all day crying over your loser X
and now you have to leave the apartment
don't worry oversized sunnies will
rescue you when you want to save face
and make your fit more fab right now you
can score a sweet deal for the holidays
because diff is offering an amazing 50
off plus if you visit diffeyware.com
toast you have a chance to win a
thousand dollars cash and score your own
diff sunglasses for an entire year or
dips oversized sunnies for an entire
year so that's uh diff eyewear
diffiware.com toast to win the a
thousand dollars cash and score your own
diff Sundays for a year and they're
having amazing sale right now on their
website they're offering 50 off in uh
spirit of the holidays so thank you diff
for sponsoring today's episode and thank
you fashion pass for sponsoring today's
episode as well so many of you guys
already loving no fashion pass it is the
truly the steamiest the steenest
clothing rental service you're getting
unlimited rentals for one flat price if
there was a time to sign up for fashion
pass this is it so many events holidays
holiday parties that you need outfits
for and they've got you covered you
don't want to be caught wearing the same
outfits like the office holiday party
the family holiday party got to take
pictures of both so you want to look
sickening but that can get expensive if
you get a new outfit for every event so
why spend 200 on one outfit but you
could rent unlimited pieces for just 39
you're saving so much money because
you're not buying clothes all the time
it's also better for the environment I
find like you know clothing rental is
kind of Genius but most of these
companies are selling like fugly Grandma
clothes fashion pass it stands out
they're not like other rental companies
because they have like actual cute
clothes that are actually being sold on
cool websites currently like for love
and lemons free people show me your
MooMoo Amanda upper Church like so many
of the revolve Brands it's really
sickening they have different plans
Jackie and I are both on the trendsetter
plan so you're getting four clothing
items or you could pick three clothing
items and two accessories every order
you could switch out your items as many
times a month as you want they are out
here cleaning the clothes for you so you
just ship it up they'll send you a label
when you're done with it and it's that
easy also if you don't want to rent and
you want to purchase something you can
actually buy now directly from Fashion
pass if you're not a member basically
like Poshmark everything is in like new
condition and it's easy to browse the
website for whatever you're looking for
we have a special discount code for your
today it is is their biggest discount
ever if you go to fashionpaths.com use
code toasted checkout you will get 50
off your first month so you can try it
for just thirty nine dollars that's
unlimited rentals for just thirty nine
dollars with code toast at
fashionpass.com Fashion pass not fugly
Grandma clothes
and you know what fashion pass free idea
that's all you take it run I know a lot
of the girls who work at passion pass or
toasters guys I won't even charge you I
feel like when people book ads with our
show they don't realize that it comes
with a free slogan
no it comes with free like like a
branding a brand book yeah also like if
you want to pay a little more we could
throw a jingle in there
right even though thuma didn't pay for
that no but like that's okay that's
priceless advertising
no that's the kind of marketers we are
yeah so true
we stretch a dollar we do shall we dive
into the fast five stories
like I guess but it's so much more fun
when we talk about ourselves I know well
speaking of us I after I finished my
terrible book last night I decided to
turn on my television I was looking for
a new Comfort show you know I feel like
we're in a lull other either it's like
White Lotus and like big shows or
I don't know and I didn't want to watch
Real Housewives so I turned on my new
favorite show
what is it the Culpo sisters
oh right there was a new episode
mcclardia the show is so good it's so
heartwarming like I'm I'm obsessed like
it's it's really my new Comfort show
like it makes my heart warm like they're
such cute funny sisters but their fights
are also like dumb but real like Sophia
is feeling Olivia's shoes from the box
with the stuffing in them the girl has
nerve oh oh she needs a good time Olivia
needed them for a shoot and then like
didn't have them
oh no that would have gotten in our
house like a sister back of the hand to
your arm like no Olivia is literally so
patient with her sisters and they are so
mean to her she's really like textbook
middle child Olivia Aurora's I called
her Olivia Aurora is really the oldest
and Sophia is really such young sister
energy and you want to know what's the
craziest thing about Sophia how she
reminds me of snitch so when she's like
with her sisters like she's such a
younger sister I just want to say taking
shoes from a box is literally something
Margaret would do yes but then she went
to film scenes with her boyfriend in
Miami Braxton because he was a free
agent so they were like filming the two
of them and her personality was so
different when she was not with her
sisters because she got to like be her
own person and if that ain't snitch I
don't know what is I should tell snitch
to watch the show
I just want to say um like not to like
correct you and be annoying but a
comfort show is a show that you've seen
a million times like you keep watching I
thought that's what you were going to
say because I actually did recently find
a new comforter oh okay so what's a show
that brings you comfort
like a new show that brings you comfort
like just it would be a new show that
brings you coming okay so I had a new
show that brings me Comfort and I'm
really enjoying it plus they're really
opening up Aurora is getting divorced on
the show like I know she's on the phone
with her parents telling them for the
first time and we're seeing it it's
really
crazy and like Olivia's talking about
how she wants to have kids soon but like
she doesn't want to bring it up to
Christian because she doesn't want to
like
I can't believe we're getting this
insight into these girls and I'm I'm
really loving it I can't say enough good
things about it and also there's just
like this underlying positivity about
the show like these are girls that like
are just loving life they have really
wonderful opportunities and experiences
and they're really enjoying them and I
just think it's a really great show and
if you haven't caught it yet I would
really really recommend it it was
bringing me a lot of Joy last night it
was giving it was like my new Southern
Charm because that's how I used to feel
about southern charm like a show I just
watch to enjoy
I have been watching um for my new
Comfort show shits Creek I haven't
watched it in so many years and it's
like really literally I know everyone
knows it's like such a good show yeah I
guess I just want to watch shows maybe
just because I have such limited time
and like I always want to either be
watching something that I enjoy or
something that's we're going to talk
about on the toast or reading a book
like I can't imagine now re-watching a
show
no I genuinely think I know we're only
like two years apart but like that's the
generational difference like even before
you had a baby like you never sat around
like watched sex in the city or friends
like I watched both I did not friends
obviously but like Sex in the City even
when I re-watch like Desperate
Housewives like the idea of re-watching
a show oh yeah it's just about having a
baby and like I just I get a few hours
to myself and like I want them to count
and I feel like yeah re-watching
something that's old like I can't talk
about on the toast it's I'm not learning
anything like I guess maybe if it
brought me Comfort that would be enough
but I'd rather watch something new and
like I could talk about the couples on
the show if you'll give me the floor
right so I'm like talking about
something like relevant I'm watching
something relevant I feel like I'm part
of no we're so committed to our craft
that's why our choices our choices our
day-to-day choices like are always
influenced by like will this benefit my
podcast right yes or no yes or no
get her done yeah like sometimes I don't
want to go to like an event or something
I'm like The Toasters need to know what
it was like it's so true
so true like people look at us they
think it's like so easy you know it's
not this life is not as easy as we make
it seem yeah no and sometimes it's like
there's more shows I could watch for the
toes but no we're not gonna like take it
that far uh no I can't sacrifice my I
can't sacrifice okay I can't sacrifice
my piece I just want to say one thing
about the Bachelor because there's a
storyline that I'm kind of obsessed with
that it's like come from the new season
of paradise but it's like people that we
know so you remember Victoria Fuller
from
um I'm kept up I'm obsessed so
apparently she got engaged on Paradise
to someone I don't know maybe the same
and they were like engage after paradise
and I guess she called it off like
pretty quickly and then quickly
thereafter started dating this guy named
Greg who was like the Tyler sea of his
season with the two bachelorettes okay
there's only one Tyler okay but like he
was like the breakout hottie from his
season yeah his last season the season
with two bachelorettes and then like
Victoria turned around and started and
now they're dating and they're both like
really nice looking and they I think
I've said this before
I think I've said this before but like
Victoria Fuller is the hottest girl to
ever come out of the bachelor franchise
like if I could choose anyone to look
like I would want to look like her she's
so stunning me Claudia that's randomly
follow her on Instagram because I know
you're like not gonna believe me but I
think you look like her
I think you guys have a lot of similar
features maybe that's why I think she's
so beautiful because I'm like obsessed
with myself no like I think that if
you've found like a picture of her as a
kid and you as a kid I feel like you
would look alike because you guys have
like really I there's things about your
features that I think are very similar
so you think I'm the most beautiful girl
in the world is what you're saying yeah
but you already knew that
so true
um that's literally the nicest thing
you've ever said to me thank you so much
and now I'm like is she beautiful or
does she just look like me I'm I'm
confused two things can be true
anyways I'm kind of obsessed with this
journey that they're on I've been
following her like since her season and
also she's I didn't even know she was on
Paradise but good she's perfect for
Paradise because like she needed us you
know a second a boost a boosted like a
second moment in the sun obviously
people were obsessed with her she got
engaged then she like leveled up to the
man from the most recent season and then
the two of them sat down there going on
the vile files
I saw that too look at them making
Bachelor relevant again no and look at
me caring but it's only because it was
like previous people and Greg was the
only name I learned from that show and
he's with like one of the few people
that I still care about so I was just
I I enjoyed that
I enjoyed that too I have also weirdly
followed her like since the end of The
Bachelor I don't think I follow anyone
Bachelor related except for like girls
who are really no longer Bachelor Amanda
Becca from our heyday
yeah remember like those girls are kind
are our age-ish right like the new
people like Margo's age but like they're
like teeny boppers Raven and I are the
same age right you know
um no and a lot of us are like like
Amanda just got engaged I mean I mean
Amanda just got married like we're in
like a similar life stage yeah Lauren
just is having another baby a lot of
them are like podcasters who have been
podcasting like for a while and so it's
just they're into the next phase yeah
yeah yeah
anyways thought I would share that and
now without going together I did it did
it do
question mark where are you where are
those [ __ ] Stripes brethren
where's Thrice
Thrice is actually getting groomed oh
you know what I should actually make
sure we're just boys doing gorgeous boy
things
he's yeah he's at the spa gorgeous okay
so now without further Ado here are the
past four five stories that you need to
know
So Fast Five
um
the fast forward is brought to you by
stamps.com
right now seasonal excitement or dread
is really starting to settle in
especially for small businesses slang
through traffic to the post office is
your inbox more like a blizzard than a
winter wonderland it's not too late to
get your holiday mailing and shipping
under control with stamps.com sign up
now and you'll be printing your own
postage in minutes stamps.com is a
One-Stop shop for all your shipping and
mailing needs for more than 20 years
stamps.com has been an indispensable
resource for over 1 million businesses
get access to the USPS UPS services that
you need to run your business right from
your computer there's no lines no
traffic no hassle save money with major
discounts on USPS and UPS shipping rates
and this holiday season you can trade
late nights for silent nights and get
started at stamps.com today sign up with
our promo code toast for a special offer
that includes a four-week trial free
postage and a free digital scale there's
no long-term commitments required or
contracts go to stamps.com Click the
microphone at the top of the page and
enter code toast
thank you mclard
okay our first story Will Smith has sat
down for his first TV interview since
the slap
I don't know why I feel like I'm having
Deja Vu like I feel like he keeps doing
like the first yeah welcome to the table
but this is that's not TV that's
Facebook watch so this is his first TV
interview with who guess who he sat down
with I don't think he would guess
Gail King no
okay hold on I think Michael Strahan no
Robin Roberts no these are good guesses
and I think actually yeah I think Gail
would have been the perfect where he
went is a weird choice
okay so let me think unconventional
is it basic cable like the first 10
channels no uh I don't know
could be no I think it's uh Wolf Blitzer
it's not basic cable
Wolf Blitzer no Nancy Grace no no
am I getting warmer no you're getting
further
I don't know
Trevor Noah Daily Show
oh okay actually I don't hate it but I
was literally never gonna guess that
because one thing about me is I have
never seen one moment of The Daily Show
with Jon Stewart or Trevor Noah like
talk about a show like that I'm not like
like I'm not the target demo you know I
don't think people watch the show I
think it's an industry plant show I
think I feel like it's regarded it's I
think there's a lot of shows like that
too that are like made out to be like so
famous and like such institutions and
then if you ever looked at the ratings
you would be surprised like your
Instagram stories get more views yeah
totally also
Trevor Noah like runs commercials for
his show where he like does some of his
jokes and they are and it's not funny
positively Dreadful like I don't even
want to call them jokes like they're
horrendous even just like him reading a
dinner menu would be funnier than some
of the [ __ ] that he says so if that's
when someone wins I can't imagine how
Dreadful the show is when somebody like
for a comedy movie or comedy show they
do like a trailer or a commercial like
they obviously are gonna put their best
jokes in there and you don't even Giggle
and it's like I don't need to laugh out
loud but I need to be like hey that was
smarter hey that's funny like an
interesting line of thinking whatever
Dreadful when I tell you you know I've
never seen a moment but I have seen
Trevor Noah's ass that's added to the
list add it to the list Claudia loves my
story about Trevor Noah's behind we were
having brunch at Soho house and Trevor
no I got up to go to the buffet and like
I was literally staring at his ass and
like it was a really really impressive
ass like it was it was those pants were
getting eaten up thank you
I know we could that's my Trevor Noah
need to know anytime like Trevor knows
in the news like we're going to hear
about the time you had oh so I was there
brunch I was there yeah you remember the
ass I do you just see him from the front
and he's sitting behind his desk at his
show like you don't know like there's a
big ass behind the desk and now you know
and I think like big asses on men is
like so funny at the play we were just
at one of the characters had the biggest
ass
and literally it was all I could look at
because he was also wearing really tight
light colored pants like khakis and his
ass was eating up those pants like
literally saying that the ass is eating
his hands please
I could not stop looking at this boy's
ass like it was crazy
thank you so it's just a little bit
about me
okay let me give you the story Will
Smith sat down for his first interview
on late night television since the
headlight making incident in March
admitting he had quote rage bottled up
for a long time he said that was
horrific right as you can imagine you
know there's many nuances and
complexities to it but at the end of the
day I lost it you know and I guess what
I would say you just never know what
somebody's going through in the audience
right now you are sitting next to
strangers and somebody's mother died
last week somebody's child is sick
somebody just lost their job somebody
just found out their spouse cheated you
just don't know what's going on with
people and I was going through something
that night not that that justifies my
behavior at all he shared at the anger
bubbled up inside of him when Chris made
a joke about his wife Jada Pinkett
Smith's hair he said quote it was a lot
of things it was the little boy that
watched his father beat up his mother
all of that just bubbled up in that
moment I was gone that was a rage that
had been bottled for a really long time
that is not who I want to be he also
broke down when he remembered his
nine-year-old nephew asking about the
incident he said about his nephew he's
the sweet this little boy we came home
and it's like he had stayed up late to
see his uncle will and we were sitting
in my kitchen and he is on my lap and he
is holding the Oscar and he's just like
why did you hit that man Uncle will
it's a good question yeah when Trevor
asked uh Will Smith what he had learned
from the moment the star replied quote
hurt people hurt people oh my God it's
giving like Millennial
um talking poster board poster board
that you get at Home Goods he said you
were asking what did I learn and it is
that we just got to be nice to each
other man and I guess the thing that was
most painful for me is I took my hard
and I made it hard for other people
the thing is is like I feel like this is
the third time we've been like we're
first time hearing from Will Smith I've
actually heard from him three times and
I think my takeaway each time is like
I'm done hearing from Will Smith like I
need a break and I want if I want to
hear from anyone I want to hear from
Chris Rock yeah also we keep hearing
from him but it the first time was like
a video on social media the next time I
was read table talk Facebook watch it
now this is like the first TD interview
and so he's obviously had a lot of
different ways to like work out what he
wants to say and I'm just like
it's still like giving like victim and
there was like excuses and someone that
you're talking about what other people
in the audience could be going through
and that you were going through
something but like don't tell us that
someone else's mother like either tell
us that you were going through something
and what it was or don't just give these
like arbitrary examples of horrible
things to make us assume that maybe you
were going through something horrible as
well maybe you were but I don't know it
just feels like you want to lead us
towards thinking that but you don't want
to say it and maybe it wasn't anything
like that anything wild enough to
justify anything remotely like this and
it's just it's weird and it's very
victimy and if you just want to own it
and be like I [ __ ] up period
no like I hate when people say like I
don't want to make excuses and then and
then they go and make excuses excuses
and also it's like the most frustrating
way of explaining yourself he didn't
even like make an excuse he just told us
what someone else's excuse could have
been right no he was like it could have
been this or it could have been that
he's like playing a game like just tell
us what the [ __ ] happened I don't think
any it'll justify anything that you did
but at least we'll get a bigger picture
of what led someone to do it but like
using cliches like hurt people hurt
people I mean like you never know what
someone's going through like agreed but
like okay so why were you hurting what
are you and if you don't want to share
and if you don't want to tell us go on
don't go on TV right and you don't have
to share you don't you don't owe us
anything and telling us about your
personal life if you don't want to don't
do another interview where you say a lot
of nothing
yeah no and now it's at the point where
it's like he's I think he wants to like
there's so many different like PR things
going on and I think when you go through
something like this you want to address
it like frequently so that people can't
say that you never addressed it and that
you can fully move on but now I'm just
like starting to be even more resentful
I'm like especially because we have not
heard a word from Chris Rock like I know
a few times he's like mentioned it in
his stand-up to a crowd of like a
thousand people and then it gets like
picked up in TMC but that's not like a
real statement like I want to know what
his thoughts are on the entire Saga like
does he think it's a big deal is he over
it it's like what's the vibe yeah I just
don't think this is something like yes
you could do your interview but it's not
like you do your interview and then you
get back to work like I I don't know how
he really comes back from this like in a
public-facing way yeah you know
yeah no I can't believe we're still
talking about this like it's so crazy
yeah it was a crazy thing that happened
it hasn't even been a year no I know but
it's like this
story I've heard already like we've
literally had this conversation I'm
telling you yeah
I think it was on red table talk he's
just addressed it in a lot of different
places and it's like every time it's
like the first time now it's the big
first TV he's gonna go on Howard Stern
he sits down for his first radio
interview he'll come on the toes he sits
down for his first podcast interview
it's like all right click bait yeah
so that's what's going on at the daily
shows until I hear from Chris Rock
uh and latilla here from Chris Rock like
I'm really not interested in talking
about this any longer yeah
or until Will Smith says something
substantial yeah
yeah
are you ready for our next story Billy
eilish is saying some stuff I know and
um I am going to unfortunately have to
quote it Billy eilish calls her
boyfriend Jesse Rutherford quote the
hottest [ __ ] [ __ ] alive Billy
eilish can't believe she's dating Jessie
Rutherford she sat down for her sixth
annual vet in the fair video interview
which was released on Monday and she
talks about her new man's Jesse
Rutherford she said quote I managed to
get my way to a point in my life where I
Not only was known by a person that I
thought was the hottest [ __ ] [ __ ]
alive but pulled his ass she began to
smile and clap while asking other people
in the room to give her a round of
applause she said Jesse Rutherford
everyone I pulled his ass all me I did
that [ __ ] I locked that [ __ ]
down she added that she's really excited
and really happy about her new man
everyone wants to to have it noted that
she is 20 he is 31 and she shared that
her love language is physical touch
okay so I do understand the concept in
which she is speaking to like she must
be really proud of herself like she used
to idolize and look up to someone and
like really was attracted to them and
she got her herself to a place in her
life where not only does this person
know about her he actually likes her and
respects her I get it why is she [ __ ]
talking like that ah pulled his ass stop
stop girly stop I agree it's
unacceptable it's giving cringe it's
giving Millennials
when I first saw it I was cringing
and I'm still cringing it is a sweet
concept this person that you respects
like likes her too and she snagged him
and that's awesome but she doesn't have
to talk like that
no seriously people are not here for the
age difference
okay like maybe I'm just becoming jaded
but like in the grand scheme of
Hollywood it's like not that bad not
that bad I also feel like Billy eilish
and even though like 20 is 20 no matter
how you say you sit like 20 is 20. I do
think she's a little like wise Beyond
her years for someone her age yes I also
just think it's like so funny the way
people get bent out of shape over
certain things and like not other things
you know like bring this energy to Scott
Disick yeah oh your book bring this
energy to your book why is it magic like
imagine a ton what's your book
it imagine the idea of the idea of you
why is the idea of you like it's being
made into a movie with Adam Hathaway
she's 40. he's 20. oh my God yeah but
everybody's uh Olivia Wilde yeah but P
but I feel like they got like
um
no because when the woman's older like
people don't give a [ __ ] like the woman
is reclaiming her sexuality and the man
is like whatever actually when the woman
like not to be you know anti-woman but
when the woman's older it's actually
more [ __ ] up because women are already
more mature than
right like a 20 year old boy and a 20
year old girl are different levels of
maturity and like women should know
better you know like men are really like
dumb like we're not like you should know
better yeah
I just think the older I've gotten and
like the more kind of um
like jaded I've become like I've become
so aware of selective outrage and I will
not be a part of the problem like people
are so dumb sometimes yeah
also the older I've gotten The more I've
realized like
how eat like the older you get you're
just a different person and so I find
when like a 35 year old guy or a 40 year
old guy like really only wants to date
like girls between 20 and 25 it's like
it's really sick like because those
girls when people in general at that age
are just so much less mature than
someone who's in their 30s 40s and to
like serially want to date someone who's
really not fully formed their develop
their adults and you know their rational
but like not formed in the way that you
are like I can't imagine dating someone
that young that's so uninteresting to me
like I want to be with someone that's On
My Level so I think it's weird and it is
I personally want to like date people
who are so much less mature than them
it's gross and yeah and it speaks to an
immaturity on their part
yeah
so that's what I've realized
I guess it's just like the year of
realizing things I feel like every year
is the year of realizing things and
that's what you realize as you get older
like it doesn't just have to be one year
so true it's the lifetime of realizing
things
are you ready for our next story
Haley Bieber has an ovarian cyst the
size of her of an apple she shared Haley
what's so sad dealing with another
Health setback she revealed an Instagram
on Monday that she has a large ovarian
cyst she wrote on her Instagram stories
and she posted a picture of her belly
she said I have a cyst on my ovary the
size of an apple I don't have
endometriosis or PCOS but I have gotten
an ovarian cyst a few times and it's
never fun she also wrote like right
where her belly is she said not a baby
because it does look like a little
um she said it's painful and achy and
makes me feel nauseous and Bloated and
crampy and emotional anyways I'm sure a
lot of you can overly relate and
understand we got this peace signs
damn that's so scary do ovarian cysts
like affect your fertility I don't know
much about them but I imagine that
they're related because your ovaries are
a big part of a big part of that whole
thing
that is she's like it's like problem
after problem yeah she also had a minute
I feel like her and Justin mini stroke
Justin's Ramsay she had surgery to close
a hole in her heart
right and then Justin and his Ramsay
Hunt I feel like these two are very
stressed I feel like they don't like let
like us see that like the pressure gets
them but like I think it does I mean
they their life is so crazy take the
salinators out of it take the right no
no like the the level that they live at
their level of Fame his level of Fame
it's hers it's crazy
no it's crazy and I feel like a lot of
like
like stress can manifest itself in
different ways yes like you can really
make yourself sick not that I'm saying
that's this is what happened I'm just
saying like I think um I'm not sure what
I'm saying but no I think what you're
saying I think that they do I think this
is also a separate thing
um I don't know if their ailments are
caused by stress but stress doesn't help
anything does it right right no that's
not what I was saying I'm just saying
like these two I just feel like they
like you look at them and you're like oh
perfect life but like when you really
look like I feel like they actually like
they they don't have a lot of Peace like
they're always like fighting something
yeah but even just like when they're not
fighting a hate or this or that like
that level of Fame like people are not
meant to be that famous like the human
brain is not wired to process all of
that
no and it's I feel like they've only
gotten more famous like at first it was
like Haley was like a model and like
Justin was this big star and like
together you know she would become so
much more famous because of him but like
now
she suggest as if not more famous than
him like she's literally like a cultural
icon also because I feel like she leaves
the house more than him
yes
by herself step out street style Inspire
the youth he can like carpet stay in the
house work in the studio keep to himself
but she's really like for her brand she
really has to be out there
that is true and I do find it very um
impressive that she's like always going
to these events by herself and like
really out here like holding her own
yeah I wonder if it would be more those
events are really you know I mean those
events are really like hard and like I
think having like your husband there
when even if your husband is so famous
like would ease the burden like you you
have your partner there yeah
but like she's literally never
photographed with him except at the
Michaela sure I never thought about it I
was just thinking she's like I was at
LACMA even though she is at event I
always just think of her like walking to
her car
well because it was like Paparazzi she's
literally like the by the way I'm gonna
make the craziest craziest comparison
right now
Haley Bieber
is the Princess Diana of Our Generation
only in the style sense so she's a style
icon
yeah but like when I think of her car
photos like I think of the Princess
Diana ones like the very like not even a
crazy outfit like biker shorts and a
crew neck and like then it becomes like
oh yeah agreed
look very minimalist it's not like crazy
Kardashian big no it's just like so
minimal and like every little tiny thing
she does is yeah her earrings her nails
her rings right yeah right and her nails
are literally shiny white it's not the
craziest thing it's not ugly like I
think a lot of trends like you don't get
it but you just copy it because it's
trendy but like everything she does and
wears like is truly beautiful and even
if you wouldn't have thought of it to do
it first like you see it and you want to
emulate it it's not like ugly clothes
totally no that's a really gorgeous way
of putting it thank you Timeless yeah no
just like genuinely nice looking same
with Diana like
stylish and classic yeah not just like
different and unique
yeah are you ready for our next story
if it's the next story that's sponsored
by Origins the pioneering nature infused
skin care brand has elevated gift sets
that will surprise and Delight everyone
on your holiday shopping list they're
wickedly talented this is the toast
approved stocking stuffer you guys yes
Origins creates transformative skin care
with naturally derived ingredients to
noticeably improve how skin looks and
feels Origins as a brand has a long
history of commitment to our planet they
reduce waste they care for our natural
resources and all of origin's holiday
gift sets um the cartons are plastic
free they're recyclable and sourced from
responsibly managed forests and for
every tree harvested new trees are
planted so to date the brand is planted
over 2 million trees around the world so
you can feel good about the gifts you
are giving this holiday season from
Origins their power by Nature proven by
science Origins is focused on plant
chemistry as a key driver of their
formulation philosophy their Planet
conscious they're redefining their
responsibility towards the betterment
for you for your skin and for our planet
and their gift sets are the perfect gift
and actual stocking stuffer but also
like for anyone in your life who either
loves skin care or who does doesn't I
feel like it's a perfect gift because
you're never gonna no one's ever gonna
dislike skincare even if they're not
into skincare because you're getting
them started on the journey
um Origins is a great brand that's
really trusted I have a ton of their
products and their gift sets are really
cute and you can get the gift sets today
available at origins.com
o-r-i-g-i-n-s.com and the rest of the
episode is also sponsored by Perfect bar
so don't go nuts this holiday season
feel yourself with the perfect bar the
original refrigerated protein bar made
with freshly ground nut butter organic
honey and 20 organic superfoods perfect
bar has a variety of products like
protein bars little snack size bars that
are all so good and good for you make
sure to find something you love my
favorite is the dark chocolate dark
chocolate chip peanut butter perfect bar
so delicious has become a go-to snack
for us they have a cookie dough texture
it is creamy and full of flavor unlike
any other bars and the fact that they
are kept in the refrigerator is so smart
to me I like never really realized how
kind of gross it is that like we eat
bars that's in the pantry they're not
like other bars
and lob and lab tour
perfect bar knows that it'll be Love At
First Bite so for a limited time they're
offering you a chance to try their
refrigerated protein bars for free how
it works is that you'll sign up for
email or text to upload a photo of your
receipt from your local grocery store
and they'll reimburse you for the cost
of one bar directly into your venmo or
PayPal account all you have to do is go
to perfect snacks.com toast get a free
perfect bar today that's perfect
snacks.com toast to get a free perfect
bar today happy snacking thank you so
much mclartia we need a great snack to
get us through this day
I know chugging along being a mogul is
like need energy you just really need
perfect bars I love those things and now
that I'm a driver like I just grab one I
get in the car it's so easy it's really
great and I'm really great for the
drivers
I'm also a perfect person so like I like
my my meals and snacks to match that
energy yeah so important
so important okay our next story a
little beef between Howard Stern and
Oprah
the Moguls are fighting the Moguls
there's infighting amongst Mongols I
mean obviously we stay above it but
these two just no I'm sorry just Howard
can't help himself I don't know what
Oprah did to trigger this and I don't
think she's done anything or even
responded but here's what she said
here's what Howard said he's calling out
Oprah for showing off her lavish
lifestyle
Howard Stern accused Oprah of showing
off her wealth on social media he said
quote Oprah's not embarrassed by her
wealth at all he said during his radio
show on Monday why should she be adding
that she loves showing it off he said
it's [ __ ] mind-blowing when you
follow her on Instagram you see her
estate her Gardens the people who
service her and you know then his
co-host Robin said service her she's not
a car and Howard said well she kind of
is she's got servants and like people
cooking and it's [ __ ] wild
um everyone does like who's rich he said
that the talk show host knows how to be
rich and light quote likes to show it
off he said which is not something I'm
comfortable with I don't think that
people should show off their wealth
Robin Quivers disagreed arguing she's
just giving fans a peek inside her life
using social media she said Robin's just
showing you her life she's not showing
off and Howard said well you got to be a
little self-aware and know that there
are people struggling out there Robin
you've got to you got to kind of think
about people who don't have to eat you
know what I'm saying I mean come on you
got to be a little aware of this
okay that's actually an interesting
point because there's something going on
on Tick Tock right now that I want to
tell you about
um because I don't really I don't live
in the UK so I don't know how I ended up
on the side of UK I mean of tick tock so
there is this tic Tacker her name is
Lydia and she's like she's kind of like
the something Navy of the UK London her
name is So Glamorous I think so she's So
Glamorous her videos have come up on my
free page all the time she's like at her
country house she's going riding she's
showing you what she's wearing a
Burberry coat here's my fragrance she'll
show her husband like she's she's
literally like something maybe on crack
she's like Royal something maybe okay
um and it's all very like
affluent it's very um what's the word
with an edge aspirational like it's very
rich
um but then you know at the same time
there's this crisis going on in the UK
the cost of living crisis like people
can't afford to like turn their heat on
in the winter like it's really um it's
bad like there's no hot water
so she made this video and this video
like literally like is gonna be the end
of her so she was like should we start
two videos off with a clap like
and she is
um talking about how there's no hot
water in her apartment so her and her
husband are gonna go stay at the Savoy
um and just enjoy all the luxurious spas
and you know whatever
and she got like the Savoy sponsored
whatever she basically didn't have any
hot water and she left and people are
taking this one particular video and
just like comparing it to what's going
on in the UK
um being like this is so out of touch
yada yada but like this is also why
everyone followed her so I feel like in
these certain situations same with Oprah
like we all live for Oprah like yeah
show us the garden and again it is out
of touch like people lost their jobs
like people can't afford health
insurance like there's all these
terrible things but that's why we love
Oprah that's why everyone loves Lydia up
until they didn't nobody
for the cost of living crisis why don't
you right your outrage to the people who
caused it and maybe the people who can
affect some change like it doesn't need
right like that so it just feels like
misplaced and agree it's not like this
isn't what she's been doing this whole
time so obviously this Sparks something
people also goes viral then it reaches
people who weren't following her before
right like this person's out of touch
when it's like oh but she's been out of
touch the whole time
right and that was like really why it
reminded me so much of the summing Navy
thing like everyone was mad at something
Navy when she got coveted and she was
like able to go to The Hamptons and get
herself a test but like you didn't mind
that energy when she was like being
fabulous and you were loving the content
before yeah so then you build people up
because everyone was following somebody
maybe because she's fabulous and she has
this gorgeous life that everyone wants
everyone was following Lydia because
it's like oh it's escapism and then when
like you're like something else goes on
in the world like you get mad at the
person for being the thing that you
actually built them up for yeah
so same with Oprah like Oprah's a living
legend now because she's this like Rich
billionaire who like just bought Weight
Watchers because she wants to and she
like has a garden and she has like staff
like that's why we love Oprah so it's
like to get mad at her for that reason
it's kind of like [ __ ] right also
coming from Howard I just I don't think
he even realizes how not self-aware he
is we had just reported a story that he
went to a restaurant for the first time
in three years he has not left his house
since March 2020 and I can't even
explain to you how much privilege that
requires to not have to leave your house
to not have to grocery shop other people
are delivering your food other people
have to go out into the world other
people who might be as germaphobic as
Howard but can't just stay home for
three years like you like you're not
self-aware so it's just no it's so true
calling the kettle black so it's just
Rich coming from him I also think with
Oprah it's it is different in a lot of
ways and also people love Oprah and
that's what we love aspirational content
but like when she's gardening like she's
teaching people I think like if she's
100 she's showing people and so yes not
all of our Gardens our kitchens look
like Oprah's but like I could learn
something from her Instagram content and
like I can maybe have a a meal like
Oprah's having I cooked it myself I
didn't have my chef cook it but like
there's things that you can take from it
no and like why is he going after Oprah
specifically I feel like Martha Stewart
does like really similar content to
Oprah like I would say they're really
the same they're always in the garden
they're always throwing like fabulous
dinners like it's giving you know
Barefoot Contessa energy so like what's
why Oprah yeah and another thing and
another thing
I do feel like there is one argument
worth making when it comes to like
being You Know Rich on social media I
think it makes you a Target I think it
actually can put your safety at risk a
lot of the times like Kim is the perfect
example of that like being so show-offy
so materialistic like people are evil
and people are hateful and people are
jealous and like I think like whenever
especially with influencers who don't
have like high level security that like
Oprah has I think people like who show
off like so many of their houses and
bags and like I think it's really
dangerous and like I'm always surprised
when I see like people who are
influencers who definitely have a lot of
money but not enough to have like 24 7
round-the-clock security being so
frivolous and like flamboyant with their
money on social media I feel like that
is a good argument
against the argument that he's making no
no no no no I'm just saying like when
we're talking about this I think that is
literally the only
rational argument against like being
rich on social media because if you're
rich like you're rich it's your life and
like social media is meant to portray
your life so what would you rather than
cosplay is poor to make you feel better
right I only have an issue with people
like Oprah who are extremely wealthy who
are living large and showing it off when
they are trying to get other people to
live smaller you know like when they're
trying to get you to conserve more and
to be less wasted oh yeah and to not fly
and not to use gas and not to have
carbon emissions when like you're taking
a private jet to go meet your friend who
took a private jet to go meet a group of
people who each took their own Jets and
you guys are also getting on a yacht
that bothers me so if you want to leave
large live large and Don't Preach to me
and don't preach to other people who
will emit less carbon emissions in their
whole lifetime than you will on one
vacation that's the only thing that
bothers me about people who believe
beautifully said
beautifully said yeah
I just think like maybe there's a
conversation to be had here like why are
you starting with Oprah like she's like
a national maybe they were having I
don't know the context for how they're
they started talking they got there they
must have just been talking about her
but I also think like I mean Oprah is
really really wealthy she's like worth
2.5 billion dollars she's a billionaire
and most people who are billionaires are
not celebrities so there's only a few
people who show us their billions on
social media
that's actually a really good call which
celebrities are billionaires Kim Kim um
Oprah Beyonce and Jay-Z combined yeah
you know what sounds like a job for
Google
you know why I feel like as a
billionaire who
Ashton Kutcher oh that's interesting
because he's always like invest invest
you know Shark Tank he doesn't even
really act anymore and he's like always
making money yeah uh Kanye Rihanna but
then there's a difference oh Rihanna
then there's a difference with people
who are billionaires and then become
famous being billionaires
Mark Cuban yeah
um Michael Jordan
okay sir Paul McCartney
wow
Tyler Perry
I love that for him I love Tyler Perry
Kylie
of course and that was the list for my
heart
wow that's a really short list oh so
wait there's more LeBron
wow
right this is a celebrity sore
billionaires yeah yeah uh Peter Jackson
he's a Lord of the Rings director I
would say that's a businessman I
wouldn't say celebrity yeah I just
wouldn't say if it's a celebrity so true
I don't know this man I'm sorry to this
man then there's Jeff Bezos as stated
not the same Jeff bezos's ex-wife has
stated not the same not the same
um Michael Bloomberg as stated not the
same not the same Evan famous as stated
not the same famous for being rich is
not the same as being rich for being
famous right George Lucas so he's Star
Wars Star Wars yeah he's famous he can
go with his favorite rings yeah in the
gray area Mark Cuban Bill Gates Mark
Zuckerberg not the same doesn't count
Stephen Spielberg
counts yeah that does count Cheryl
Sandberg not the same Warren Buffett not
the same Kylie okay so that's really the
one that's like I said really short yeah
that's so interesting
and it's really except that's why I was
surprised by LeBron because it's really
all people who like started companies
not like who got famous like they're not
billionaires from the reality show the
Kardashians you know what I mean yes no
you and I don't think Jay-Z's in your
business a billionaire from his music
it's because of Rock Nation you'll never
become a billionaire just by working for
someone and working for someone else
exactly
it's interesting
it is interesting yeah no one on there
works for someone else really
yeah you could also divorce into
billions right that's how I plan to make
my billions even though I'm never
getting divorced that was a joke Ben I
love you
okay well that's the Fast Five
I mean we could go there if you wanted
to like about the way about it you could
become a female billionaire if you get a
divorce
yeah because sorry one
yeah like I do believe that like she
deserved half and like you know she was
at home like she like they both it
wouldn't have been able to Big Amazon
what it was had she not you know been
there and done her part well there's
this thing like most of the richest
women in the world are are widows or
heiresses or divorces
yeah yes too we gotta do better
in the sense of like you need to
uh marry ability no women or we know we
need to become more self-starters
self-starters yeah I am pledging to
become you know a female billionaire who
didn't get her money from divorce or
from an heiress and I um I'm gonna need
your guys's help so don't forget to
share this podcast if anyone wants to
buy my comedy special like come on just
share the podcast I could do this we
could do this together I think that's
where all good things would come from if
you just share the podcast
yeah so true nothing bad ever came from
sharing the podcast not that we know of
yet
um so those are the past five quite
robust today thank you jaque for your
hard work and dedication to your craft
thank you so much for acknowledging and
seeing me for the work that I do
thank you guys so much for listening to
the toast the millennial Morning Show
where we deliver the past five stories
you need to know every Monday through
Friday on YouTube so if you're watching
this on YouTube please don't forget to
subscribe give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so at
Spotify iTunes Stitcher public radio I
got radiocast box all the places so
we'll be listening to podcasts find us
the toast leave a five-star review about
how beautiful stunning and smart we are
and wickedly talented hope you guys
having a crab Tuesday and we'll see you
tomorrow for hump day bye love ya bye